convinced himself that in case of the
capture he was planning this recapture
and he did it quickly like you said but
boy he did it for obvious human reasons
right which was like he's eyeballing
that open that his rook is now very
active and a direct threat that was why
we saw this move Bishop e6 yeah we're
moving that loose piece and also showing
up lots of possible threats on a 7 right
defending against them and then we saw
this move Knight takes even registers on
as if that matters in this possession
yeah but it isn't it remarkable that
blacks King is you know just stuck in
the middle of the board can't castle you
your size this Knight on e7 makes an
incredible impression no you don't get a
927 too often takes we are anticipating
Queen c5 check not the only check but
now here's the issue what should we do
with our King Maurice pointed out one
variation where when the Queen came over
to h5 our King on the h-file is suddenly
vulnerable but let's say King h1 in this
particular case and this well which
recaptured which capture should we do it
with either the Queen to head over here
for h5 or should rub d8 be rook d8 is
kind of like that in-between move trying
to develop with the tempo against the
Queen maybe that's too double-edged not
sure about that one either things like
you everything cured up at the moment
after the a but you know Queen takes e5
that's a very reasonable looking
movement boy again maybe maybe a move
like rook to d1 it may be favor
do you want Luke to d1 I are always
looking at attacking moves first you
know hitting the Queen rook to d1 no
idea anything like 96 96 and you know
romantic checkmate in thanks to the
bishop on h4 yeah I was thinking
memories
22nd century chess or I was thinking
romantic jazz you're thinking 19th
century he's leaning 23rd century got it
but then after Queen h5 who's attacking
home this is really wild the night is a
bit it looks great in some ways but it's
kind of trapped I mean you mentioned
night good that's a good move because it
does protect the bishop and looky looky
there's a checkmate because the Brooklyn
f1 also guards all those potential
escape square is on the FI all right so
that captures we still allow that
checkmate that Paul Morphy made so very
famous in the 19th century blacks King
cannot go to f7 thanks to the rook and
he can't take the rook or move here
because even though the bishop is pinned
in an absolute pin it's still on the
board and it depends the Runk and with
morphine you bring up a very important
first chapter of American chess history
and here we are today making American
chess history at the thing you look up
and yes and a lot of people don't know
this that here we live in the modern age
of the celebrity superstar but back in
the 1850s it's widely recognized that
Paul Morphy was the first global
celebrity he came from New Orleans he
was a very young man he went to Europe
played blindfold simultaneous ha's and I
had the most mature ik career virtually
any chess player in the world and was
celebrated and renowned the world over
that's an American genius I know that uh
whoever I was in her own shook one of
the top players in the u.s. says that he
absolutely loves more face games oh
let's go back in time and play him in
that
exactly yeah we're gonna invite somebody
to dinner Paul Morphy would be on my
wish list absolutely so as we're as
we're trying to decipher what's going on
in this position I'm gonna have to again
we don't we we've got King h1n the move
rook the eight looks oh we've got a
couple work the eight was played okay so
that briefly thought after after all
queen c5 check oh no he didn't wait we
need six check all right Queen b6 check
two whites king well the difference here
is that the Queen on c5 is no longer
going to spin across over here to h5 but
it provides extra support to d8 which as
we saw and all those checkmating
variations was a critical square exactly
rub the eight with the tempo against
White's Queen and now this very sly
Queen d2 d1 yes indeed and then the
knight 187 chose another point stopping
things like were to g8 which would right
so now now that things have clarified a
great deal I'm again I'm going to refer
to Maurice and say Maurice please tell
us what Houdini and the greatest chess
engines in the world are making of this
position indeed this is an ideal
position for the chess engines to sink
their teeth into and keep analyzing and
billions of billions of positions per
minute the fact that they can look at so
many variations and sift through all the
junk is an incredible tool for us as
chess players and certainly we use it as
grandmasters there was a time when
grandmasters would have rejected out of
hand any suggestion about computers
those days along dead particularly when
IBM's deep blue defeated our illustrious
champion Garry Kasparov so using it as a
tool in this moment ninety xb3
was given as the correct move and here
the computer actually like
takes b3 it didn't mind this position at
all feeling that in fact this bishop
holds up blacks position this Bishop is
guarding this the f7 square the d5
square the f5 square so it wasn't
worried about any move which we might
say I'm just losing in exchange aren't I
here with Bishop takes six it thought no
problem just take back and let blacks to
in this position with the knight
preventing that came from castling moves
like Queen f4 about to happen this point
actually being a dangerous one to take
because of rook to e1 in some position
so I thought rook takes me three was the
best move here instead got a plate C
takes b3 after Knight takes C takes b3
here and now Queen b6 check not too
pleased about thought queen c5 check was
still the correct move in this position
and after that there was a crazy line
here by the way Queen c5 check instead
of Queen b6 check King h1 and if rook to
d8 here's something you might not like
to see Queen takes d8 check sacrificing
the Queen King takes very flashy looking
line you're wondering where's the
discovery why would you do this well
night at five check and suddenly you
have to be careful where you put your
king if you go here then then Knight
takes on G several check and something
if you go here then BAM that horse has
been hopping around who just stole your
queen
so Knight to f5 check the best move is
just to walk into the pin on the other
side and after this position has
suddenly the position has simplified
when you look it's actually material
even except for what's going to happen
is just a trade of queen for rook and
this position is actually dead equal so
nakamura could have gone for this line
instead after see takes b3 he played the
move Queen b6 check which the engine
doesn't like and now King to h1 rook d8
and it's thinking now after Queen e1 the
Queen should have been more involved on
the c5 square but now on b6 is a little
more offside and it likes
White's chances here white is ready to
play Queen g3 you have to start
defending this position does black and
the material is even by the way with the
salient feature dude in the middle comes
back to the same thing we tell our
students get your King out of there
don't be in the middle of the board it's
not so easy for the
by King to figure out exactly what to do
so Nakamura with a very challenging
position and we can see his face right
now his expression saying ah I don't
like this going for a win and I might
even lose so a challenge to Nakamura
here in this last round of the
Sinquefield Cup back to you Jenna yes
Wow
I like to see this a HD quality video
here with Nakamura faces you you
actually get to see use eyelash very
expressive boy after all of those
variations Jenna I don't know about you
but my brain hurts trying to make that
work and I didn't see a great discovery
but that night f5 with a 97 96 idea
that's that's a beauty yeah what caused
him to probably play Queen b6 instead I
know but now what Maryse makes it so
clear that when the Queen was on c5
black's Queen was much much more
involved and that ePHI pond capturing
that ePHI pond and potentially going
over to the H file to get a play against
White's king that was probably key
remember when he played the move Bishop
takes b2 to gain material advantage in
order to justify his strategic
difficulties well at this moment he
still has the same strategic difficulty
but he doesn't have the material the
extra pawn in his pocket so to speak
yeah definitely who Karl under pressure
let's go to our marquee game on right on
table 1 between Magnus Carlsen number 1
Levon Aronian number 2 this game at the
moment is determining first place when
we left the situation we had just seen
the move rook on a wand a to keeping a
protective eye on this pawn on a5 as
well as protecting the bishop on V 2 the
game continued with the trade of bishops
rook takes B - pardon me Bishop takes me
to rip takes b2
Knight e8 okay so we understand that
what LaVon is saying is this night on c4
is really strong I want to trade a pair
of knights to decrease the pressure
against the Ponte on e5 by the way keep
an eye on this pawn on a5
that one's vulnerable as well Magnus
played that earlier only game to try to
Lockley a6 lon but it can also come back
online
precisely he went rook b2 to a2 covering
up his pawn we have seen there after
Knight e8 to d6 please says black would
you please trade nights and straighten
out my pawn structure that may be double
rooks on the C file as well one day
which would be a big strategic advantage
I guess I saw you in with a 65 and
before and a very good Sicilian for
black nothing doing says Magnus he
dropped back with his knight on D 2 to
protect his knight on c4 keeping that
night firmly entrenched but now I'm
looking gen after this move Knight d2
let me just highlight these two very
nice square C 3 and d 4 these make very
attractive outposts not that this is
mean this is blacks best move or
anything like that but look at that
night gen once that Knight comes to the
C 3 square followed by the other night
it looks like black has got great
outposts for his knights on c3 d4 I
don't know but I'm just kind of feeling
a little bit here that it's actually
Aronian who's carrying the battle and
definitely on the clock as well so this
is for the thing feel Cup far from over
we've mentioned many times in this
broadcast that we've had incredible
chests gas journalists grandmasters from
all over the world and the United States
one special gas we have Frank whadda
Lupe who is the acting director of the
today's chats Federation he stepped in
at a time of great need for the USDF and
he's already been doing some pretty cool
things he is here with Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley thanks Jen with acting
executive director Frank Guadalupe the
u.s. Chess Federation and thanks for
joining us
so Frank this is an incredible
tournament the u.s. CF must be so proud
to have these kind of events taking
place on American soil it is tremendous
event and it promotes chess and
obviously that's what the USA is all
about we're very thankful for them and I
I've been here many times before I was
here that 2010 US Championship as an
arbiter this year as the chief arbiter
of the US Championship I came some time
ago to measure that giant chess piece
the largest in the world and I started
find a measurement of that so it is
city's exciting to be here
I am just thrilled to see the big chest
movement that corrects and Jeannie and
the folks at st. Louis checker have
generated or for everybody
indeed and their mission as well of
using chess as a tool to help kids in
the scholastic arena that certainly
drives well with your mission as the
USCF not only to our nation but also on
a personal level as you know Marisa was
the chief from and director of
Supernationals the largest scholastic
chess event ever over 5,000 kids so I I
feel pretty good about what they're
doing here about all the chess promotion
and the development of chess here and to
me is incredible I walk out you know in
the sidewalks there people playing chess
I go next door to less there's a sport
bar okay yesterday instead of
Alabama vs Texas A&M with Johnny Manziel
the Heisman Trophy winner or today man
in vs. Manning you know Denver versus
the Giants you know all you see is chess
in the morning torsion in and that is
amazing to me he just hunts it I'm
really excited about that as a New York
giant fan myself you know I find a
pretty incredible
yes what are the future plans for the
u.s. Chess Federation well hopefully
we'll use events like these to further
promote to our membership hopefully we
will have not just in the san luis area
but all over the US and the world really
people watching these and will continue
promoting i we just can always say a
promotion in the USCF to try to get back
members who's who players whose
membership expired over two years ago
and say hey you know check us out you
know come back to us and I just started
that runs for 64 days so I'm very sad
about that I'm really honored and
excited to be part of these that they
asked me to you know take the helm for
four humans until we hire a permanent
director there and I you know this is my
life I I love chess I always follow it
in two weeks I'll be going to Tallinn
Estonia for the feat of Congress the
World Chess Federation Congress and I
know that in there
my friends throughout the world will be
talking about this event indeed we wish
great things for the USCF we also know
that there are some new fans that are
going to come to chest because of an
event like this what would you tell them
and how do they join your organization
well easy citizen all they have to do is
go to us chess there orgy and there is a
link there to join the Federation
that's number one and number two is I
will tell the young folks especially out
there that you know chess is all about
promoting the mind
okay I am biased because I got a couple
songs who play chess I have one who's a
master and I was very fortunate he got a
chest collar ship to study engineering
so I am I am I feel that not only I have
received benefits from chess
personally but I think that anybody can
out there so it is a tremendous game I
love it I didn't know how to play chess
till I was in college and in the states
I was in Puerto Rico in that stage they
had the Fisher boom back in 1972 Oh in
1968 when I was in Puerto Rico we had
the coupon move and a lot of you know
who I'm talking about
Julio Carly took a plant and correct the
world Union champion in 1967 so that's
why I wasn't around
it was born actually maybe not even one
yet but I do remember the name absolute
linear I think he didn't call it for now
and obviously in not playing chess doc
playing chess many years ago but back
then when I was a teenager we all talked
about who Lee took a plan you know
because he had wonder the world junior
champion and I see this play of sheer
amazing world number one number two and
the u.s. number one number two and I I
just I just think and hope what would
happen if one of our young players right
now our best bet of course is Hikaru
Nakamura but what if our young players
become the world champion I think it'll
be amazing not just for the USCF chess
in general but for a young generation
yes it's what it's all about well thank
you so much Frank Guadalupe for
everything you have done for chess in
the US and continued success with the US
Chess Federation Thank You Maurice
gentlemen as we know him Frank waddle
Lupe
the US Chess Federation you want to
become a member US chess dot o-r-g back
to you Jenna yes Thank You Maurice and
Frank Lautenberg day also the zonal
family absolutely and just again for
those of you who may not be aware of how
the organized world of chess works in
the United States the United States has
Federation as a host of programs not
only in terms of who's going to be
invited to the men's women's Junior
Championships holding those Scholastic
Championships we have the Olympic teams
the world teams that all of these
programs are supported by the USAF
there's chess and prisons chess
philately
Cheska chess scholarships the list goes
on and on if there's a lot of things
that the USAF does a major year 2013 is
we had the biggest test tournament in
history so 2013 could be just absolutely
landmark year forecast the strongest the
biggest let's break 9 absolutely and
this prank said I mean he's the personal
recipient herma son's benefiting from
chess but really it is the mission of
the USC F to bring chess to every home
in the United States so go ahead and
join and check out yours chest out our
size to yellow to Catalan I'm the editor
of that and we've got a lot of cool
features grand actually my brother just
wrote an article about he's top five
tips for chess players going back to
school we're gonna have an article from
Grand Master or Ian Rogers on this
tournament as well lovely and one more
thing
Frank Waddell EB stepped in when the
USAF needed an executive director
immediately but actually a personal
friend of mine Jeanne Hoffman is gonna
take over that position in November oh
good okay I was wondering who was going
to become the permanent executive well
we all have to update me on gene and
haven't heard of her but I'm sure she's
gonna come with new energy in vitally
important key position yeah her US chess
young in the green educational record
has done a lot for kids in chess
including co-founding nine Queens now we
do have and there's an announcement on
the US chess website as well about that
does look like we're gonna get time
moves in our Kamsky nakamura game so
let's go right back to that all right
the action is
Thank You Emily hot I mean you couldn't
really expect more from this battle I
mean I love the Sicilians my favorite
opening I used to play in tournaments
and be sad when I didn't get I want to
display every round here we have one of
the most exciting ones and it looks like
Nakamura's King ended up on d7 well
let's see how okay when we left it we
had seen this very sly move Queenie one
that we were all intimidated by this
Queen on e Wan could potentially go to
g3 with that tempo against the bishop on
g7 he Carla's move rook d4 was both
offensive as well as defensive Hikaru is
in a position now in case of Queen g3 to
switch his rook across the g4 not only
protecting the bishop on g7 but also
attacking whites Queen that wasn't what
got ahead of mine instead
gotta play Bishop f6 so that his bishop
would no longer be under fire by that
rook and after this trade of bishops
Bishop takes f6 he takes f6 that's one
heck of a night outlaws yeah well
exactly that that Knight is now firmly
anchored and basically with this knight
on e7 it basically says no way just
simply no way are you going king side
after this recap decided exactly because
we're making a virtue out of necessity
had to go to DISA right rook on d4 at
least is blocking plugging the D files
those kings on an ax major immediate
danger but working one on the board
challenging the D file looks like the
most natural move I can think of in the
position and this is a kind of a tricky
little move rook to d8 x-raying a
potential defense and basically what
Cara was saying is if I'm going to
survive White's onslaught and then it
do it by holding down the D file so he
has played the move rook on h8 to d8 and
how to evaluate the position there I say
who knows you wonder where is that black
he's gonna slide back to ete 8 cuz that
would allow after Queen 85 right Oh
Queen e5 has been played
oh no I'm saying after Queen dee well I
was just saying if you were gonna touch
touch the rook on a d4 with the move
Queen e5 the idea was to prevent any
ideas of the King sliding to the Queen
side and you're absolutely right the
move King back to e8 would be forced you
get to the black King right bowing rook
to e1 and then after Queen to d8 I can
be 71 Jack but I'm not even sure yeah
you're too clever for your own good you
know I'm gonna have to talk to your
daddy
rook takes and you would be winning that
is correct yeah because you can't
continue to guard the DA rockin c7 Queen
takes d8 precisely and after however
after all of this instead of playing
rook takes d1 once again you have that
really clever rook G for sliding across
and protecting that G eights were and
again it looks to me like there's no
immediate kill I don't see it well an
incredible defensive things action here
by not immoral well he has to pull out
all the stops not only to save the game
but he's still trying to win the
tournament
right I mean and what is the time I'm
sorry yeah I mean of course it's
unlikely but even a draw could give him
put him into that three-way tie for
verse only of LaVon wins right exactly
about to come back to that game because
LaVon it looks like avoided a repetition
ah good LaVon yeah I'm gonna find out
how we do we have a clock issues on both
games Nakamura only was 50 minutes and
Carlson was less than 20 minutes so both
Kamsky
and Aronian with massive time edges in
these games and we've got something from
an Grandmaster Ashley on how this
exciting final round at the Ziegfeld Cup
is shaping up very exciting indeed Jen
if you remember earlier in the year
carlson in his bid to play anon for the
world championship entered the last
round needing to win a game or at least
draw in order to play Anand in that game
disaster struck and he actually lost but
thanks to his nearest rival Vladimir
Kramnik also losing he was able to
essentially back in to the world
championship match not very impressive
was the rest of the world looking at
that kind of performance by the clear
number one player in the world well here
you know he's won 11 tournaments out the
last 17 as you've mentioned imagine
winning 11 out of the last 17 Grand Slam
tennis events or golf events
that's simply unheard of so there's no
doubt about his ability to be a
front-runner his ability to dominate the
competition but people are starting to
look for chinks in the armor and that
loss he had in that that tournament made
people wonder is he really ready to take
over the entire world the entire planet
particularly the World Championship well
here in this game he's not showing it
Aronian is pressing him with the black
pieces doing exactly what he said
equalizing out the opening and now
massaging this advantage and you see
after the move Knight to d6 Knight bTW -
he played this move Knight back to b7
did Aronian and after the move Knight to
f3 he came up with a fine maneuver
bringing his King into the game we know
the King belongs in the center of the
board in the endgame because it's not
going to be checkmated in any way and
Carlsen decided to do the same thing and
now King f6 shoring up this weakness and
getting ready to pluck this pawn off the
board Carlsen play the move rook a for
eyeballing a weakness of his own on the
beef
square but now it's really black for
choice here and yaza maneuver you
mentioned earlier I just love putting
the night back on d6 is playable and
then after this move why the heck not
Knight to b5 threatening to come into c3
and by the way there could also be some
pawn demonstration on this side with g5h
for trying to play on two sides of the
board you've got to love black here for
black only two results win the game or
draw Carlsen only two results draw or
lose there's no real winning chances for
him in this position he's just trying to
be stoic and solid so as not to lose and
end up blowing the tournament lead and
being forced to play a playoffs or even
worse if Nakamura pulls a rabbit out of
the hat and wins suddenly Carlsen would
find himself completely out of first and
staring up in Nakamura as the champion
of the Sinquefield Cup back to you genin
yawns wow what drama we're having here
in this final round yet world number one
world number two doesn't get any better
than that playing for the championship
and Magnus in a little trouble and in
fact at the moment LaVon just went over
to the Queen side and clipped upon he
has played Knight captures a5 let's
bring that up on our board for a moment
as Magnus Carlsen for the first time in
the tournament behind material and let's
see what had happened I did like that
positional maneuver that Maurice had
mentioned bringing the Knight to c3
instead LaVon said hey give me your
pawns baby knight on beat 7 captures a5
what LaVon is hoping is that this rook
on c5 is going to put pressure on this
pawn on c2 so he was hoping that Magnus
would try to win his pawn back
immediately with the trades trades
Knight coming back
takes a six rook takes c2 and blacks a
pawn to the good and with a better
position and attack with that beautiful
Rock and the King well poised everything
looking in black villain exactly a great
harmony in blacks camp so Magnus didn't
want anything to do with that variation
so Magnus pulled his knight back and
said okay let me try to do some action
of my own maybe I look forward an
opportunity to playing Knight g4 check
and capturing this pawn in the near
future I just don't see this as being
sufficient for real compensation I see
this as a position that Magnus is trying
to hold right hold on to like ideas like
94 because 94 is a hassle and working
one can sometimes come back into the
position now that III is protected so
just to show what to just I put on the
board what you were just saying that in
case of Knight d4 Knight g4 check is
more than a half so you you forced the
King to step back and white would
capture this pawn at the moment this
night on a5 doesn't really allow you to
do any real action down here on the c2
square now we're getting lots of
exciting developments in Kamsky nakamura
so right back for more on that stay
tuned to the Sinquefield
club here in st. louis as our final
round leaves all three players that we
must be caught earlier any of these guys
can win it could be Nakamura Carlsen or
irani on so don't go anywhere stay with
us accent ahead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we have a result in our final round
of the Sinquefield cup which makes the
most exciting finale possible the game
between a can takea nakamura was drawn
and that means that we could have a
three-way playoff for first place but
only if huronian wins otherwise magnus
is in the driver's seat he's got the
lead at the moment that's right and we
had a quite wild game and it's exciting
that we have that I can see here with
Maurice Ashley to talk about this tactic
fast thanks Jen with us champion gata
Kamsky after his last round draw against
Hikaru Nakamura got a that was a wild
game we were analyzing it we could even
analyze it ourselves honestly we have to
go to the engines and it looked like you
had a great attack but the engines were
saying no black was always okay what
were your thoughts during the game well
I you expect this line from Kim so and
then I came up with the Bishop c4 over
the board
you know just intuition and I was pretty
happy with my position you know I Castle
they're back had some weaknesses and you
know I thought that was better and then
I saw this idea to sacrifice the pawn
but then go for the attack and you know
put all my pieces there and it looks
like really good but you know that's why
he Cardozo car you know he excels in
positions like this and I just thought
you know okay keep keep keep keep keep
sacrificing keep attacking because some
point maybe I'll get a draw well you
know I got really excited at the moment
where I played Queen e1 because I told
my knight sort of cuts off from this
position yeah I thought I had an
advantage here because my knight is so
strong and I have this idea Bishop f6
and his piece on the Kings side a kind
of stuck and all I had to do is take
control over D line and then I'm quite
okay
so when he played rugby for all right my
man I used to play rugby one first you
know just to change the active rook and
then keep the night going to a5 possibly
so the wine was so he takes on d1 21
Bishop e5 Knight a5 and pushed by v
rocker v f6
let me switch over to another fee so we
can take a look at those lines right for
those who won't follow us easily so here
you were saying
rugby one rogue do you want write a new
variation okay excuse me
all right and you were saying the main
line was alright no saying when I was
taken t1 Queen t1 and Bishop e5 and
night at five uh-huh and it still looks
like well it's still saying equal no
matter what you do you know you probably
do Sarah one was saying
off-camera that you played really
agressive chess this tournament you're
known as a very solid player that you
nuanced positions massage people but
this tournament you seem to play really
exciting entertaining aggressive chess
and yet you were somewhat unrewarded for
that all that effort well I'm not sure
about massaging chess but I like that
amazing
well okay but I felt this tournament is
where we can play for the fans and I
don't have to playfully result and I can
choose to go and play interesting chess
which in my case is playing aggressive
attacking chest so the first round
against Magnus I played this Wildish
five movement was really crazy and then
some other game also had like this
aggressive for notions but these guys
you know they're so young and the
accurate they see everything they like
computers so you know and and you see
what the computer does he in any
position he shows like zero zero zero
and they find all these moves and
sometimes the aggression doesn't pay off
okay it was interesting I liked this
event and I have to say thank you to the
organizers it was amazing and it was a
privilege to play here of course and it
was fun well say Luis has been very kind
to you you've won a few championships
here and st. Louis this one may not be
your best event but I'm sure you'll be
back to play again absolutely - indeed
well thank you so much for joining us
u.s. champion de gata Kamsky he righted
the ship at the end didn't lose any more
games after a couple of losses in the
beginning so tough chess we congratulate
him and back to you Jenna yes
well again I just have to repeat myself
I just feel very
strongly about this that gotta really
pressed in so many of his games he was
on the attack and men talk about coming
up empty-handed it's really unjust and I
just want to point out that in this
position in the game today between gotta
as white and Hikaru is black he Carla
had to find this very awkward difficult
move rook d8 to prevent what was a
winning threat in the position Queen e5
and then what we saw was this repetition
for those of you who missed that it was
a forced repetition and Hikaru's dreams
of determining his own destiny right
turns no no he's
yes fingers crossed go LaVon and let's
pull up that Carlson game just for a
second when we get Nakamura set up for
his postgame interview here and while
you do that I'll just repeated a funny
tweet from a strong chess master from
Maryland Alex Burnett he tweeted that
gotta camp ski is the most legit chess
player the dude is a Russian ode he but
he still kills so hard well I'm not sure
I know what all that means I mean I feel
like a dinosaur that I gonna have to
learn Street or or social street
whatever so here we go and we actually
had a couple of really thrilling moves
in this game as well okay just about 93
let's go back up but so have you have
you been refresh this board yet yes I
did I just brought it up so it's it's
quite refreshed we did see this capture
Knight takes e5 copy over yet maybe
we're okay let me close and copy it over
so we have one game remaining in this
inaugural event the sink fold Cup and
all the marbles on the table right here
for this matchup so we had this position
we saw the move Knight takes a five as
well as Knight III they got to this
position and h5 was played too
this Knight g4 ideas oops right I got
the wrong Thank You 2094 I now and then
the rook slid over so now that freezes
the knight on a 5 because the pawn on a
6 will always hang in case of a retreat
and now I play the fun move work today
for sacrificing the exchange and I don't
think that that exchange could be
captured Knight retreated to e1 holy cow
kingi 7 okay we're gonna have to well
think a look at why is that or can it be
captured in a minute - but first let's
go to grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura who is
with Maurice Ashley indeed Jen the
number one player in the United States
number 5 play in the world Hikaru
Nakamura after a draw with gotta calm
ski Hikaru we know you wanted to win
this game you played a tremendous
tremendously crazy opening line it was
wild
it was interesting chess and even in
this moment you play this move Bishop
takes B - what were you thinking at the
board to win this position arose because
frankly I thought if I didn't take the
pawn I was just gonna get crushed in the
center I mean I was way behind you
development my King was stuck in the
center so it just made a lot of sense to
me to play the move I mean really
normally I would prefer not to play this
this sort of position or the sort of
game but I mean considering the
circumstances of I mean I had to at
least try to tie first so it certainly
it was the sort of position I wanted
considering the game but then after that
I actually think that God uh I wouldn't
say I'll played me but he he out
calculated me because in fact at one
point in game I thought I thought I was
actually much better but I'm this is
very very creative tactic that I'm
almost certain God it would have played
which position was this this was a
position after okay so okay I thought II
five was strange I'm with twenty four
stars I thought if he had done
I actually was much more concerned with
f5 I thought if I was and then Bishop h4
was also very very unclear
and think there's play for both sides so
but it was right around here I actually
just I miscalculated this whole whole
resulting line so after fishby 697 I'm
124 124 so 95 yeah so takes takes Bishop
e6 90 X 90 takes pawn it C takes yes he
takes it's critical that's right yeah
actually I missed this whole idea
because I thought that no matter how he
took I could go clean see five track
King h1 and I can play this move rook da
the the point thing that if you go
Queenie one here now I think for Queenie
one I go roopd for the position is much
different because of Bishop f6 here I
can I can take take Queen h5 Chuck can
you do one and now I've rook h4 whereas
in the game you'll see my queen is on be
stuck so I never have these ideas are
transferring everything to the h-file
the problem is after work t8y can go
clean takes D I mean I completely missed
this this concept I mean because this is
the whole point C takes b3 as it opens
up the C file we did see this line in
the game what of course with the help of
Houdini three I think it's just winning
four white cakes Knight a5 k t7 but d3
actually gives King c7 is the move
saying that this line might be more or
less equal for you if the rook see one
bishop back to f8 and it thinks that
you're still in the game more or less
equal position you felt that you should
have gone for this line to avoid of
course I should have gone for this but I
mean it still of course should be
I know maybe 96 here or something should
be yeah probably 96 in this position
should be completely equal but still it
makes a little bit more sense than games
in the game actually I just end up worse
like Queen e1 or d4 it's 126
yeah like in this I mean like here I
suddenly like panics I didn't see a good
idea but luckily I was able to well
originally I wanted to go fish mafia
actually that was my or not fish my food
I wanted to go work t7 sorry I've
instead of rook d4 I wanted to go rook
d7 oh sorry yes I wanted to go this
route e7 the problem here is very strong
with between g3 and and now I think I'm
just I can more or less resign because I
mean I'm gonna lose some some material
there so work d4 is the only try I mean
to try and activate I mean because
basically here the drawback is I am a
king is not and I mean my Kings not my
king is in the center so it's quite
quite open but at the same time and I
don't need 7 it's preventing my team
from getting to safety but also it has
no squares either so it's a matter of I
mean trying to take advantage of the
center or not no I've not yet made it
and if I if I can survive tonight and
game that I'm probably gonna end up
better and I've chances to win so that's
why I played worked before them Bishop
f6 I mean all this is very forcing
perhaps at the end I could have tried
clean d6 instead of King e8 but it's
still he can take on d4 and go rook f3
and I thought this was a repetition also
and at that point I mean I just died
okay I was happy with the draw
well the draw does give you a tie for
first right now at the moment and
crossed it in his game is under some
pressure against the Vaughn although
it's kind of looking more and more equal
LaVon was pressing the whole time he's
up a pawn right now what's your opinion
of this position um looks very drost to
me actually I mean at first glance black
pockets double e pawns I don't really
see I mean if black would get that e6
pawn 285 and with the knight on another
square I think LaVon would have good
chances to win is black but I mean to me
this looks very Josh I don't really see
many many ideas for either side did you
keep your eye on this game while you
were playing your game or was it just
enough dealing with depression yeah I
would have liked have paid some
attention at least but considering how
quickly my game got I was out of control
I didn't really have much of a chance to
look at the other game but never the
last I mean I was just
not trying to trying to play well okay
III don't know whether I played well or
badly but still it's it's a good result
well mathematical chance of still tying
for first at least clear some place and
second at least in this tournament what
are your thoughts about the organization
of the tournament and the event itself I
mean it's very well organized I mean
across the board I think with everything
the what rocks and Genii sinkholes have
done not just for this term for the club
in general and in st. Louis - it's great
also I have to say this is probably the
first time I've ever been to a
tournament anywhere I mean even in the
US where you know when I was when I was
walking here yesterday and the day
before and even today for that matter
there were some people who were cheering
clapping as I as I entered the club and
I think that speaks a lot to the
enthusiasm of the fans and the people in
America and it was really great feeling
to know that there was so much support
for me
it's just too bad that I couldn't quite
you know well with your style we expect
great things in the future and
congratulations on a fine tournament and
good luck in your future endeavors thank
you us number one in number of five in
the world Hikaru Nakamura a great result
for him we'll see great things in the
future
back to you Jenny yes no doubt and it's
not quite over yeah winning and then
Nakamura will be tied for her exactly
Wow
and again I just have to say personal
comments that I found Hikaru's play here
to be scintillating entertaining and
really making this event his
fearlessness at the chess board and his
desire to mix it up and cause chaotic
positions really puts the pressure on
his colleagues at all times and really
just hats off to him have tip to him for
making our lives so much easier I mean
you know for us to bring you a good
broadcast show we need the players
cooperation and that means biting chest
and your car
brings that each and every day and a
little bit more precise I mean just
amazing things cuz you did have a couple
of struggles in the opening both today
and yesterday that's right not getting
much with white yesterday and then today
obviously being in some trouble but
still managing to hold it all together
which is incredible and I it's funny
that line with me it's very good but as
soon as you saw that move he was like
yeah gone for that but but I just a
backward Bishop move at the end of a
long very he said that's right when
they're you you think when you're
looking at it and there could have been
something else as well yeah you can
totally understand why he went for a
line that made it harder on himself but
he managed to draw right well that I
just like that really beautifully
precise work on h8 to d8 yeah move that
really shows his class
speaking of class we have two
world-class players a first and second
in the world playing for all the morals
here on board one let me just refresh
the times bring the game into our viewer
board for a moment sorry that was the
wrong one really has a blade for the
wind because he's actually sick if you
draw this game he he also doesn't you
just guess third place right which kind
of doesn't really reflect the the kind
of like drama of this last round battle
but it'll just get that a 30 hey third
rise so he's actually playing for a
possible $40,000 swing here right if he
manages to win yeah if you manage this
win he would share no well yes they
would have a playoff right so I possible
40,000 higher swing which is pretty high
right yes precisely gotcha gotcha so
we've had a couple of moves and let's
try to decipher them for our audience
for a moment we had this position rook
e1 a1 was Magnus's move trying to keep
black bottled up here on the Queen side
and tying blacks forces to the defense
of the night on a5 Livan tried to mix
things up with this move rook d4 this
rook simply cannot be captured because
after a move like Knight takes d4 and I
just have to give that move a simple
question mark for maybe a very big
question mark after captures recaptures
black is for choice in numerous ways I
think White's Queen side is dropping for
example if the knight had to come back
then with this move
d3 captures Knight captures blacks Queen
side pawns are really deadly here in
this position not to mention that the
rook on a1 is hanging as well so Carlsen
didn't even really consider this but
still a nice little sacrifice
sacrificial idea that you see from time
to time when you have this like
beautiful square
right tigran Stephen in petrosyan
legendary world champion made a
comfortable living sacrificing occasion
of course I have an inspiration to the
law exactly yea Armenian drug ambien
so after ninety one the I didn't get a
chance to look at it but let me go back
it was exactly at this moment King
dropped back to e7 I was wondering why
LaVon didn't capture the pawn on e4 and
I'm still trying to make that
determination right yeah why not after a
move like Knight d3 attacking the rook
the rook can slide over to be 5 square
and I don't quite see what issues LaVon
is facing here at the moment these two
pawns up I mean don't forget and this
rook although it looks uncomfortable as
soon as it goes to the d4 square Knight
did too followed by Knight c4 c4 whew
that's dirty that is just that's just
cold I like that Wow
c2 c4 let me know
give up on this variation quite yet
because it's a very forcing line the
main point of whites move c4 is that if
we opus on we're hang out rook on e4 and
that's not good but let's go back for a
moment here and I'm just looking at this
crazy line Knight takes b3 so at the
moment I'm all kinds of ponds up but I'm
hanging a rook pawn takes d5 pawn takes
b5 now two white rooks are hanging let's
drop back or go forwards with this rook
for a moment and just get this position
what do I have three pawns one two three
four pawns for a piece this needs some
serious judgement and consideration
ice I'm not sure what's going on here
clearly it was rejected by LaVon I'm
certain he saw this line but it's a
funky line I'm gonna have I'm gonna
refer to Maurice on this one and ask
Maurice if the computer can gave this
consideration in it Maurice helped me
out in DD as the computer did give a
consideration to this line very wild
line after this rook hanging on the
square
a4 rook to a6 attacking the knight
trying to use this rook more actively
not one to get the rook passive in the
corner as your estimation is quite
correct you don't want to be back here
dealing with the pawns you want to be in
here starting to eat stuff and get it
off the board and if Knight to b8 is a
line the computer gives now rook to a8
this rook wants to be the active one it
doesn't want to be the passive one back
here so after Knight takes a1 rook takes
b8 and now you see that the rook is
doing all kinds of work from behind in
this position rooks
like to be behind pawns when they attack
so the rook is coming but in the back if
you come here with the move like c6 and
of course I move like rook to b6 can be
played and the active rook is opposed to
passive rook on a1 with a passive night
sitting actually on a 1 instead and
although black has the extra
worth paw and it looks like he's gonna
drop another one and white will be able
to start proving the energies with his
piece now this line is not entirely
clear especially now I have to rook to
d4 so maybe we need to go back and move
rook b8 in this position it still gives
this line with rook to d4 as maybe the
right way to play to stay active with
its own rook and saying that white might
get an advantage with a move like 9 to
c5 so this is an interesting line he
could have gone for LaVon but you see
it's too crazy why do this when you had
complete control of the position no
reason at all
to go for this line grabbing this pawn
and getting this craziness happening on
the board for black although looking at
the board now it's so solid that maybe
he doesn't have anything anyway
but I don't think he wanted to lose any
control of the position like this line
would suggest so he's just sitting back
and saying let me see if I can grind
this kid down with so much time left on
the clock without all those forcing
variations back to you
genin yes that's right and he's got a
big time advantage still but we are
between the 40th moved 20 minutes for
LaVon and seven-and-a-half for Magnus
and I do think there was a good reason
though for him to go for that line and
that's simply the 20mins situation you
know a draw and a loss his LaVon third
place and just $30,000 that draw or a
loss is the same result so it's all or
nothing that's what's what you're saying
that's right so he's got to go for it
well I mean of course as a number two
player in the world I mean every rating
point that he loses is you know very
could be detrimental to certain you know
wild cards and all the other important
things that he needs for his rating all
right
on the other end through the 20th
standings he wants to go for lines that
include a lot of wins even if you might
lose more often right I never really
felt it during my career about ratings
and things like that in the last round
game I always look forward to you know
my dream in each and every tournament I
played in is that I hoped that I would
be in a situation where I was playing
for first place in the last round I mean
that was what I lived
or as a grandmaster the moment I secured
my Grandmaster title it was all about
winning tournaments and that Larsson
most especially just hammered that home
to me yes sir
you've got to win tournaments that's
what it's all about winning tournaments
I like that attitude
oh yeah Advent was the fighter the
consummate fighter and gentleman too by
the way
so we go back a dream though that LaVon
after starting this tournament with that
horrendous blunderer would be playing
for first place in the last time
exactly exactly well only LaVon
well maybe not only live on his fans as
well so we saw this position and this
retreat kingi seven avoiding that wild
line I'm getting I here Maurice very
loud and clear whites rook an active
white rook really could make the
advantage in whites the whites play but
I tell you for pawns for a knight and
all of those passed pawns born I would
have really looked at that very very
deeply indeed King e7 was lavon's choice
f2 f3 very solid moved by Magnus Carlsen
fortifying a kind of fortress trip thing
and by the way why White has really tied
up these two nights on the Queen side
the night on a5 can't move because the
pawn on a6 hangs and the nights are
codependence to quote Rex after f3 LaVon
slipped down with rookie 2 rookies whan
he stepped back saying please help me
out here capture my rook and undable my
pawns of course Magnus rejected that and
this is the current yes I have one more
move from the lon you did play King to
d7 in this position and once again he's
showing that he is still playing for the
win because had he played the move rook
D - well Magnus would have been very
grateful oh yes let's grab the sinking
or cop only the 70,000 and it's a field
captain say and he's like and he's 11
what is it 11 out of 17
confidence boost before playing that
World Championship match in November and
Grandmaster Ashley your thoughts on
which way this is gonna go hey Jen 12
out of 18 66% winning percentage in
tournaments yes that's something we can
only dream of doing as grandmasters well
in this position I think there was a
critical moment in the game for Aronian
I myself unlike you yes I'm not a pawn
grubber I like active play and I think
there was a moment when Aronian really
lost his true chance to build his
advantage it was right here when he took
on a five with his night it looked
delicious you're grabbing upon your
going to go up by a pawn and force your
opponent on the defensive but after this
nice move Knight to e3 Carson said
what's the deal you you're up upon but
your piece is frozen on the square it
seems like forever how are you gonna
untangle in this position and we've seen
so far that Aronian has been busy trying
to untangle but he simply can't get away
without dropping his own a pawn so he's
taking his time there what was a good
alternative
well maneuver you mentioned he has and I
just gotta come back to it the move
Knight to d6 trying to put pressure on
this night and after Knight FD to the
move Knight to b5 now that's active
piece play dropping a knight on c3
pressuring this pawn putting this rook
in a prison over here having to stay on
this side and it looks like your idea of
maybe eventually playing Knight to d4
sorry let me go back playing the move
Knight to d4 I mean this looks fantastic
the active Knights now maybe there's no
obvious way to break through he still
has to deal with making some pawn breaks
with the move g5 but this seemed like a
very reasonable way to play and maybe he
just saw that that's not enough and so
he grabbed the pawn now he's pressing we
have this position currently on the
board and he's played the move King to
d7 the one thing I had to say this is
clear and I hate to let you know this
Jenny as we're gonna be here a while
he's gonna play for a while he's going
to make this young man suffer first the
first time control has to be reached
and then the next time control would
have to be reached he's up upon right
now he's gonna say earn this Sinquefield
cup young man world number one I will
make you defend and defend and defend
because I now have absolutely no losing
chances you're the only one that can
lose and that cannot be a good feeling
for Magnus having the white pieces and
being tortured and you're the best
player on the planet that can't be cool
and we see him there analyzing the
position and dealing with his time
pressure so being made very
uncomfortable and I know there's a guy
in India hmm let's not name him yet that
guy is watching this and saying oh yeah
show me how you torture this kid and he
will be taking serious notes for those
of you who don't know I'm talking about
it's the great Vishwanath on Anand back
to you genin yes Thank You Maurice and
yes indeed Magnus looking very
uncomfortable he actually just unbutton
one of his shirts so one of the buttons
on his shirt I think the female fans
across well to be fair I mean he does
win the tournament with a draw so of
course you're gonna get pressured and
has to be in this unpleasing situation
it's nice that the stakes are 70 K
beautiful tournament win right before
your World Championship match but also
gotta go back to the opening I mean if
he's gonna play for the World
Championship he's got to be getting an
advantage with white right you can't be
happy with this right hasn't been he
hasn't impressed us with his plate with
white and today you know he walked into
a variation he knew LaVon has prepared
very well I mean this is his bread red
yeah that also the game between Nakamura
featured this opening so it's
interesting that he didn't have a little
more up his sleeve
maybe LaVon surprised him at some moment
remember that move Bishop c5 was a novel
change so perhaps he thought the lines
without Bishop to c5 were more promising
for white and then he just had you know
was working over the board and things
went awry
you know also anon please double King
Bond stuff as well right so likely to
see this kind of stuff in the World
Championship right Magnus may have
thought that he was going to have LaVon
for lunch and huronian thought well I'll
have you for breakfast
so he got in his novelty before Magnus
could get in his and that's the
difference so far in the advantage to
LaVon whether you can make this serious
or not I'm not sure
first of all Maurice I think you really
did nail it with let's go back and see
what LaVon may have done differently
grabbing that a fight pawn as juicy as
it is maybe it it lessened his winning
chances but I'll go back to this
position for a moment as well and don't
forget your messy work d4 line where it
with a rookie 5 at c4 that was another
option right must-win scenario well I'm
thinking that as it turned out in the
game
LaVon ended up dropping back with his
King after playing the move h6 h5 and
I'm just wondering if LaVon couldn't
have improved over the game variation by
dropping his King back right away if we
would have seen this move rook on e 1 to
a 1 in that case then after rook d4 all
of these variations where we end up
sacrificing at piece or exchange in
those crazy lines it's a it's a big
improvement that the King is actually a
little bit closer to the king side
because we did have that move c7 c6
which may now be defended and it's those
nuances those small little things that
often mean the difference between
victory and a draw so I'm thinking that
maybe King 7 was a better chance after
you've made the decision to capture the
pawn on a fight let's move ahead let's
rather get to the game position move by
and see how things are stacking up right
now we have this King to d7 move right
so avoiding the perpetual of course
repetition is as Murray's pointed out
we're in for a long one because
Aronian needs to win this game yes need
to try and he will and he will okay and
we do have this move Knight
II won which kind of well it does
significantly demonstrate how these two
rooks are putting such intense pressure
on White's position that Magnus doesn't
seem to have found anything better than
going back and forth with his knight and
you know that's not pleasant when you
kind of have this helpless feeling of
the only thing you can do is move your
knight back and forth what this move
also says is okay what's your
breakthrough how as black are you
planning the win this game with this
offside night on a5 and Maurice I don't
know if you have any suggestions for us
has despite the difficulty Magnus
obviously faces are there any
breakthroughs for for black
well actually after 91 so it looks like
Carlson's down to two minutes could that
be right no way let me I'm sorry let me
refresh the board and we'll come to
Maurice very shortly I was just
wondering I didn't see any anyways to
kind of a breakthrough in this position
is what you're saying for black right
right wait you know he's got this
fortress and maybe Maurice has something
something insightful as usual well yeah
as the most insightful thing I can say
is Magnus you better hurry up you only
have two minutes left on the clock two
minutes and 14 seconds LaVon has 15
minutes and he's trying to find
something anything he can to force this
young phenom to think more about the
position unfortunately there are no pawn
breaks anywhere to be found and we know
that you need pawn breaks in order to
open up a game and the problem the main
problem is he can't untangle these
Knights how was he to do it to move this
that would mean dropping this guy to
move this night with me dropping this
guy so how do you do it meantime very
solid pawn structure remember he's down
upon his Carlsen but the pawn he's down
is one of these two ponies right here
right I mean that's it and they're
doubled and they're not going anywhere
so although ease up upon the pawn
structure leaves a very bad impression
which is why he needed to have more
piece activity than this position so
looking at it closely as it really looks
to all rights like Carlsen is okay and
he will make the draw that he so
desperately needs in order to win this
tournament I really don't see how
Aronian makes any headway in this
position yeah not no levers as you like
to say right I mean g5 g4 only one I can
see in the position but that just looks
like it's gonna do more harm trading off
a bunch of pawns and right now those
plans are already held back by by blacks
so really Aronian would want to be doing
something on the side of the board where
he has an extra pawn but use as you
mentioned those codependent Knights or
right I mean the hang-up these are
really bad right not a functional
relationship at all well let's let's
imagine a line let's let I see one
possibility for LaVon it's a bit of a
stretch that bear with me here Jen
imagine King goes back to c8 so the idea
of this maneuver as I'll make clear
shortly is that with the king now on the
b6 square protecting the knight on a
five in case you do nothing then in this
particular variation I have this
opportunity of sacrificing in exchange
this way and the difference is is that
after you take my rook I recapture this
Knight is adequately defended so that
rook takes a five is not on your agenda
here something like something like 93
perhaps it's necessary but then I was
thinking I could maybe play Knight c4
here and have the in-between move on the
a6 pawn player takes a six but the nice
thing for you is that you do have the
pawn that you really wanted to come home
with giving you extra play this b-pawn
is the danger you're right you don't
really want that Avon as much no so of
course the Magnus is not compelled to
repeat all of those right well I was
just I was just showing the variation
where where if Magnus plays passively
there is this long-term plan in the
position that from where we currently
stand where this King could make this
journey to the b6 square r-e fortifying
the knight and opening up that
possibility of sacrificing the exchange
because there's no levers and so it has
to come down to rook sacrifice exchange
sacrifice it's possible well by the way
let me just get an update on the game a
couple moves and socially to played and
a knight f2 I'd like to remind everyone
that 45 minutes after the game is over
if there's no playoff if there's a
playoff and we'll stick around for that
for
five minutes after the game there's
going to be a press conference and
trophy presentation that will be live
streamed as well so stick around for
that all right
so 91 we do have this move the rook came
back to d2 okay interesting decision and
now instead of night III the night has
moved to f2 making the possibility of 93
trying to keep this rook snared on the D
file not sure what I was after Knight to
f2 q c8 was played Carlsen only with one
minute laughs only four moves left in
the game industry and he's gonna get
another two minutes in 30-second
increments but up with something here
that makes a magnet thing then
definitely the right time to do it
okay no is the time okay so we have seen
this King track Trek all the way to see
over protect the the pawn just like
basically to overprotect a knight rather
on a5 right which is a concept which I
know you love mins of it's one of the
overrated chess thinkers we got the head
shake but of course the concept of
overprotection is that when we protect
the night on 85 more that will then
release our other pieces in this case
the possibility of the rockwork possibly
the knight on c6 and we do have moves
after the move king CA and check the
time again for me gen 3 8 seconds for
Magnus Carlsen no way really work to be
by playing Magnus to better make a move
fast certainly when I want the sinking
of Cup being decided by a freeze a
moment of freeze oh my goodness that
would don't larger happening by this
young athlete and world number one chess
player grandmaster Maurice actually is a
got some thoughts on all this indeed a
big opportunity now present for Magnus
Carlsen to neutralize blacks advantage
it looks like he can play right now
the move Knight takes B for a little bit
of a shocker in this position Knight
takes b4 showing the problem of the
overprotection
of these nights the codependency I think
you called it once yes or maybe it was
Rex Sinquefield quote and so in this
position now suddenly there's just no
way to keep the connection all in here
so Knight takes before will be possible
and then rook takes a five and sadly for
us this could easily peter out into an
even position after it takes takes takes
and now rook takes a six and the e6 pawn
is hanging as well so he may be able to
play this move right now with only a few
seconds on his clock he needs to hurry
up let's see what he does in the game
yeah that's right oh so a little
simplifying possibility here for magnus
carlsen and that's what you're looking
for when you're in a worse a man
definitely you want to look for a way to
simplify it so that you don't get ground
down which obviously increases our
chances of making a mistake
and it also allows your opponent to
improve their position at their own pace
now judging from the board we're about
to get these moves in but it looks like
Magnus didn't play that Wow I thought
that was it yeah on the board I thought
that was a set a fabulous opportunity as
Maurice was pointing out the knight
takes b4 instead he played h4 so missing
the simplification opportunity with very
little time on the clock King b7 in
reply so continuing along with your plan
of king to b6 and uh fortification now
how does this change matters with no
eggs before I'm not sure maybe it
doesn't maybe the move h3 h4 was useful
and in case we get that variation that
Maurice was showing us where all of
these you know you had this wholesale
exchanges happening rook takes rook
takes seconds no way let's see it oh
he's got to be nervous if maybe you have
already made a move we're going to wait
for an update here but this is this is
pretty critical obviously it's not fun
if you have to make that kind of
simplification simplifying rather
calculation when you are move 3 9 you
sure wish it was like move 41
you get those extra time and now is the
moment because once I can be six is
played it will no longer be possible
precisely that's now whenever so can be
seven one more chance for Magnus to go
for this line if he misses it now
LaVon will continue to press exactly
and let's see it looks like we've got a
move in yeah we're looking for we're
looking for what I haven't work on it
looks like can be something work on one
to a two Wow no night before no night
before and now after after the movie
predict king b6
I guess what Magnus is is saying is
everybody's mutually tied up go ahead
and show me now I wanted to put my king
on b6 because I was hoping to sacrifice
an exchange on c2 now that this rook has
been chased away is bottled up on the bc
v square maybe Magnus is saying look
I've got a perfect fortress you can't
because I can't move my knight on d4 so
much because I the before upon is
hanging right just to show to the
audience what Jennifer means is that if
you move your knight you do give up the
pawn on b4
and then we might get c2 back but that's
not not clear at all no it's not clear
to me maybe Magnus has just said look
I've got the perfect fortress dude what
are you doing we have seen Magnus find
himself in bad positions and create
fortresses before notably against
Nakamura and an endgame where Nakamura
was pressing on the white side of a c3
Sicilian up a piece I think her right
and Magnus kind of just like solid and
that's what he's resorted to with this
move rook on a1 to a2 heaven he has made
the time control by the way with the
move king g1 that is his 40th move now
you mean after what after after oh sorry
oh sorry okay - still one more move for
Magnus Carlsen so we're expecting b6 and
I was suggesting the move king g1 and
that would be me
so in that and then he'll he'll be able
to take a breath and you know think a
little bit more calmly about the
position and you know try to make a
drawl here and capture the first ever
sing fuel cup to the very last moment
boy Jen we I must say too by the way
not only do I feel privileged I think
everybody does as well that the players
have really made it great for us I mean
the type of chest that we're seeing here
is chess at its finest and so again hat
tip to to the players over and that's
why me like so many other people
watching all over the world we're a
thrilled when rec CEO that I came and in
an interview with Maurice Ashley and
said hey we're planning to do this next
year yeah and maybe even better I mean
that's what they're always trying to do
here at the st. Louis chess club is go
from success to success and imagine each
and every time how can we make the
tournament more dramatic more exciting
for the spectators for our fans and next
year's event
I think Rex and joy have been Tony have
been discussing a six player double row
it's up in the air but the idea
Sinquefield Cup is a great idea and you
know a lot of the credit goes to people
who've come out to st. Louis bought
tickets for the amount of course major
because the fact that you know you might
only be one person but the fact that you
do that 200 other people do that you
know more than that anyway more than
that but like just the fact that so many
people have done that shows the Chess
Club and the organizers that hey this
was a really good idea right so thank
you to everyone who listened to us all
week and then especially to people who
actually made it out to st. Louis and a
big thing and I actually got a question
from one of our listeners later about
you know Wrexham field that's all these
great things for chess you know what can
we do to show a Rex and Jeanne that we
appreciate their efforts but it's not
that hard
joining the Chess Club joined the museum
right
those those are the things that that
they they really appreciate because they
be grateful for absolutely yeah we have
over a thousand members and may be great
to continue to increase that number it's
actually a lot cheaper if you're out of
town to get a membership so even if you
only can make it out once or twice a
year it shows your support for chess
that you become a member of the st.
Louis jazz lab and - one of the things
that Tony and I discussed is the
memorabilia we've got a lot of
memorabilia we've seen all of the
players flashing their Sinquefield Cup
t-shirts and their jackets for the US
Championships men's women's and junior
jackets or you know they've got and
that's all on the store - so any support
in that way would also be appreciated
indeed indeed and we've got Grandmaster
Maurice actually with his thoughts
indeed Jen and I would say calling all
visionaries take a look at what's
happening here the tremendous support
for the club for chess the groundswell
of fans coming out so fascinated by the
game wanting to see the world's best
players the u.s. best players and just
chest itself I know they're members in
our audience who could put tournaments
like this together certainly they do
mean I've had the practice but they can
give a ring to tony rich enjoy bray and
say how are you guys doing it not only
do we want to support your initiative
there in st. Louis but in our own cities
where we want to put on world-class
events give us some guidance and we'll
do the same it's clear that the fan base
is there that the chess fans are hungry
for great events great activities and
it's about time I think that chess rises
to the level of poker Jed I know you're
a big fan of poker it's about time we
started seeing chess televised monster
events like this even more prize funds
it seems like chess has finally arrived
and here in st. Louis they're showing
exactly why Jenny yes
that's right I mean I Neer's don't we
definitely impossible for a chance to
become much more
mainstream that it is now in this
tournament with it being streamed by a
Fox Sports Midwest and featured in the
big screen every day this is this is
step one but this is by no means the end
if you think about what's happened in
the past five years you can only imagine
what will happen in the next five and
you all at home are really a part of
that so thank you we do have a king be 6
by LaVon and we expect that Magnus
Carlsen has probably made time control
and so we'll we'll find out what what he
played and now Yas are just predicting a
move that does nothing kingi one but
waiting yeah Ron what are you gonna do
how are you gonna improve your position
you have a pawn congratulations right
I'm gonna go for the cop exactly so
we're gonna go back and move for a
moment as Maurice is saying that maybe
King be sick oh no convinces not yet
played okay music not yet played I've
got of course we have the pond in this
side it's pretty thinking pose yeah very
nice thinking suppose a bit of a duck
face yeah by the way I like I like it
when he goes into the full frontal lobe
with the hands as the Vulcan death grip
all these layers for it I mean another
very well dressed Grandmaster obviously
magnus carlsen sponsored by G star raw
but Levon always looking quite sharp as
well maybe they're thinking about the
the Queen's ayala coming up next month
in their World Chess Hall of Fame's the
biggest probably fashion and chess event
since that Magnus Carlsen diverse the
world event that happened in New York a
couple of years ago that's not so long
ago right now tell me more about the
gala for a moment he is in honor of the
museum's show an Alexander McQueen and
chess and fashion each other okay cool
yeah there's gonna be a lot of
initiatives around the Queen and getting
more girls into the game as we discussed
earlier on the show
gotcha all right very interesting
something to look forward to we seem to
have a move King so we were a spankin
King b6 to fortify the night
and protected cross indeed mark time
King Jiwon in this in this case
literally marking the 40th move which
allows him to get up from the board get
a glass of orange juice and refocus his
efforts to hold this game and become the
champion here yes and this is very
common that after making the 40th move
players get up from the board and try to
refresh their mind I can't help it's
such a tragic funny tragic comedy story
so what happened was in the Grand Slam
event there was Hikaru Nakamura playing
a Spanish Grand Master opponent and the
last round and Hikaru had turned to the
arbiter and said have I made move 40 and
the arbiter not allowed to give any
information to the player didn't speak
it to her carros eyes he thought he saw
a slight nod Hikaru got up went to the
players room poured himself a glass of
orange juice came back to the board in a
Spanish opponent Francisco pons had said
I'm sorry you've lost on time and the
point was with that loss instead of the
expected victory that he had on the
chessboard it was a swing of 30000 euros
that's a big amount of money and of
course inquiring minds like myself of
course went up to Hikaru and asked him
well how did the orange juice taste
acara was that really was it wasn't
worth $30,000 this had to be the best
orange juice in the whole world
because like you say you felt you felt
terrible of course that's a very sad
story and you see a lot of players so
paranoid about that possibility that
they kind of treat move 41 is if it's
move 40 and I know Viktor Korchnoi would
have sometimes to be sure that he made
the time control with spanked out of 40
first or even a 40 second move when he
wasn't a hundred percent sure that
associated was luckily and the pide pide
40 minutes you actually when you make
your 40th move they're supposed to see
the
minutes exactly and that's where Hikaru
made his error and not just checking the
clock and seeing that he had gotten that
Bonus Time
well even the best players in the world
make mistakes and in this case not a
mistake on the test board right but you
know we also see the zero-tolerance role
that fidei puts into the fact and almost
every every time there's a World Cup
there's some incident it does seem
terrible it's a terrible just a bad rule
in your men they're really bad that bad
yeah real real bad we've got this
position it's it's looking more and more
like a fortress to me and obviously with
his move King f1 g1 Magnus has basically
said look I'm gonna be moving back and
forth with my king from here on out you
Livan you've got to come up with
something really clever to break this
idea it doesn't seem like anything but
your idea of king b6 allows us to
untangle I mean we're not gonna play cuz
because we can't really move the knight
on c6 anyway because of the view for
pond right so that Knights totally stuck
this Knights to me if I can move that
and play c5 that would be the way to go
right
how's that not feasible we can't get our
king to c5 right right so all you know
going all across the board I see these
two knights are stuck the rook on b5 is
fine but also stuck nothing's happening
on the King side h4 shut down human
potential possibilities of g5 and d4 not
like that would have ever been good but
you know just uh there's it shut it down
just as he said yeah so I'm looking
looking looking I'd love to see a
playoff only because I grow that way I
like I like to see the players going
down after exciting meal of no Knight
but it looks like Magnus has secured the
Sinquefield Cup because I do think he's
got a fortress position jacket and we
will see you Levana continue to rock his
brain now oh yeah of course he'll do his
moment to be as creative as possible in
trying to squeeze a some some juice from
this position some mornings use that if
you will okay grab master Maurice Ashley
how can you squeeze something out of
this
unfortunately Jen it looks like this is
coming out of concentrate not
fresh-squeezed that this is not going to
happen the position is so blocked there
are no levers as we mentioned you need
pawn breaks in chess and as it stands he
can't reposition his pieces to do
anything positive in this position it's
just completely stuck but I want to show
you a different position we've been
talking about Carlson and his match
coming up against Vishwanath on Anand
the world champion that are going to be
playing later in November in Chennai and
later this year in Chennai and this
position is a good memory for Carlsen
from that matchup he recently played
against Anant at the tower memorial back
in June and he got this position where
he knows how to play chess you know
we've seen him here playing very blocked
chess defensive chess dare we say a
little bit boring for him right because
he knows how to win and he played this
great game against uh non with the white
pieces and he this position he played
the movie for now that's what we call a
lever open up the position get an attack
going let's show you the effect off this
lever after this exchange obviously the
pawn was threatening to play the move e5
and fork the Queen and night he played
the move Queen to d7 and another lever
in the position bam d5 cracking the
position open this is the effect of
pawns marching down the board they bring
energy to the position they wake up the
pieces behind them after C takes d5 he
traded Queens in this moment and after
rook takes he played a fissure esque
type move I believe he has the game
Fischer Petrosian from I believe it was
their candidates match where a beautiful
night took what didn't look like such a
great Bishop but in this position the
activity of the bishop started to rain
with Bishop to h3 anon realizing all
sorts of threats to his position cap
tactical ideas move this king away and
before taking upon 'if I've dropped on
the board chasing this night trying to
prove its inferiority instead of playing
94 i non-drive back with the passive
knight to e8 die to g8 Bishop takes rook
dropped back to d8 and then what do
levers do they open up lines for the
pieces and now the rook posted up on c7
controlling the entire seventh rank this
pawn now desperately moving down the
board and then the last move Bishop to
e7 and are this passed pawns just
getting ready to go down the board this
rook will nibble on this pawn and blacks
pieces just a mess levers levers levers
they are the energy of chess finding
those right pawn breaks but as we see in
the game right now there no such breaks
it doesn't exist and that's what makes
this look like it will end up in a draw
and we'll give Magnus Carlsen the title
of course Levon Aronian still working
very hard trying to see maybe he can use
piece play to win the game but the young
phenom looks real relaxed right now
looks like he's just back in Norway
somewhere in his living room just we
used to call this Thank You Murray so we
used to call this California cool and I
mean there's Magnus kind of leaning back
you know life is good let me think how I
want to spend the $70,000 I'm about to
win a lot of space and where is the line
is kind of a scrunched up yeah I'm just
trying to see if there's anything there
but not finding a thing and this could
be the last will be the last serious
game Magnus plays before we seen him in
the World Championship and against a non
in India in November
put that I can't win you know what I was
looking forward to it before this
tournament but now that we've been here
and we've seen these games and you know
Magnus has been
and all the players have been so
gracious its I'm even more excited to
see that and I tell you how can you not
be a fan of Magnus Carlsen what he's
done in this tournament how he's handled
himself at the baseball football games
the signings the media
he's just been easygoing and really a
perfect guest and he's funny and I think
he's gonna get funnier in the next few
years down that's my my bold word about
Mac is he's gonna enjoy life to the
fullest funny funny hair because he
seems like he's always quoting comedy
shows quoting Ali G and I somehow I
think that his sense of humor is gonna
continue to develop a course that'll be
really an interesting and charismatic or
world champion if he defeats an on honey
hole I'll get another crack at it just
22 years old agree Jenna I'm just
looking once more at the webcam and just
how relaxed Magnus appears and
throughout this whole event one of the
things we understand this is a most
elite tournament ever held in the United
States a lot of stress on the players
stress what stress I mean Magnus has
been smiling off the board throughout
the event and and at the board you see
him very cool very collected I'm a
little bit surprised he went solo on the
clock in this game but he calculated
that he held he could get this fortress
position and he could hold it inspiring
game let's be honest but still a very
inspiring performance and you know great
both Nakamura and Carlsen in this game
kind of showed their defensive chops in
a lot of ways absolutely better workman
like performance the only thing I could
see and unfortunately in this exact
moment the king is not in the ideal
place let me just play this move King be
seven and assume this for them I mean
the only thing I can see and I'm not
suggesting that
Livan go for broke because this could
really backfire badly there is a
sacrifice Knight takes b3 in the
position but this unfortunately with
white keeping this pawn on b3 it's
not gonna work I'm afraid any kind of
defensive move that holds this pawn on
b3 should be good enough for the draw
set the simple was like it's not part of
me not good for a draw but maybe even
for a very big advantage
you already had c5 and you need a lot of
things
93 in c4 but even then work before it
would be in the menus right you knew
that you need a lot of extra tempos to
make this desperado sacrifice work it's
the only thing I'm seeing and although I
saw LaVon take off his jacket a minute
ago and really hunker down to try to
find something there it's just so
blocked even the glasses came off he's
really yeah you can almost feel you know
him screaming you know like I gotta have
something I've got to have something how
could I pose any problem than my
opponent it's just not there it traces
back to the rule of heads and one of the
problems we were discussing about the
Ray Lopez in the very beginning of the
broadcast that you know a lot of the
lines and they're in the main line where
Lopez involves moving the knight on c6
so that you can play c5 and get a
greater stake in a center Brier or the
chigorin with Knight a5 so many were you
late for c5 exactly and here it's just
like if only the lion could play the
move c7 to c5
right oh yeah then it'd be a totally
totally different story he would have
the lever we're talking about if by a
miracle this pawn were to magically
transform itself to the square c5 then
the lever c5 see for blasting open the
position is something that black would
aspire for aspire towards and try to
work make it work here unfortunately the
pawn is on the wrong so well we just
can't move the knight on c6 because then
before hangs and we can figure out a way
to make that sacrifice work you know
that would be the game changer but
before is a critical pawn so yeah just
to put that in perspective if you could
played the move knight on c6 to b8 with
the idea of untangling the Knights with
night on a5 to c6 if you have the time
to
make that maneuver sure black would be
in great shape unfortunately any retreat
by this knight on c6 as you were
mentioning just hangs the b4 pond and
there goes all your advantage completely
and suddenly I think again it's white
for choice right I mean you you would
have to find a way to play it whereas if
I would lead to something but just seems
to be better better for white and if he
doesn't have this then we got to agree
to a draw sometimes it happens that way
I mean a fine a finally played game by
LaVon I think he'll be pleased by the
fact that he held an edge but the truth
is that wasn't enough to be decisive
right and so he's got his hands in his
head Magnus leaning back and opposed oh
you don't see him in that often much
more relaxed than usual I'm used to
seeing that I'm used to this California
cool Magnus used to play with the
helpers from chess club in the Dutch
League when he was younger and even as a
young boy sometimes he would actually
curl his feet up you know but now that
he's so much taller I told him damn man
unless you've grown a foot since I've
seen you but when he was small and cute
let's say he had his feet underneath him
at times talked but this is his normal
easy pose fantastic athlete you know I
was talking to some of the kids at
Webster and they said they said that
they played a basketball and soccer with
Magnus okay and I said how is he really
in basketball I'm ashamed of the
Americans wait a minute these are a lot
of I mean these guys aren't iron
arrogance either for the most part right
they came here to do opportunities that
once there my foreign students come to
the United States for their higher
studies absolutely and end up finding
ways to stay work visas and cetera and
then we have a you know stronger
American tournaments than ever
yes of course of course in here in st.
Louis where the epicenter of collegiate
chess with Webster as the national
champions that's right and you also have
a pretty strong us just weed team the
st. Louis Archbishop's right but don't
forget but the Seattle Seattle is the US
Justice League champions the Seattle
sluggers yeah maybe Seattle all good
things come from Seattle as we know I'm
sorry I'm drawing a complete blank and I
would love to see a playoff but I don't
see any way that LeBron close enough
LaVon is going to break through the
fortress that Magnus has constructed so
let's take a couple tweets we've got one
from our friend targets Benson in Oslo
he said out of the last 15 tournaments
Magnus Carlsen do not win six and those
are the towel memorial 2013 Norway 2013
and that was a big closed tournament in
Norway that Network also participated in
fuel 2012 Tata 2012 London 2011 in Tata
2011 and that was the one that knocked
more actually won it was his best
performance so far that was his break
breakthrough performance he car was yes
we also have a question we actually have
something that you mentioned Andrew
laughs and asks he has what an idea for
Black Knight d4 with the idea of Knight
takes b3 if work takes before Brooke
takes for up Knight takes rook and
Knight takes b3 and asking about the
compensation there
okay well let's at least it's worth a
look thank you for the kibitz knight
Knight d4 I think the the line that he
gave was rook takes rook takes Knight
takes Knight takes b3 what's the
compensate
probably insufficient this night defends
the rook on a2 so that after captures
Knight takes rook takes Knight takes the
problem is that while black has a number
of pawns for his piece the reality is
these are very ugly pawn structure and I
just think it's insufficient that in
fact that would be to whites advantage
once more
anytime black it seems to me any time
that black cakes undertakes such
desperate action like this type of
sacrifice it's actually going to rebound
against him and whites gonna be four
choice oh we've got we've got some other
comments on it Kwan's our ponies what
are Knights that was from Maurice I was
a little bit surprised by the ponies
reference peonies I always thought that
the ponies the cavalry were the Knights
so somebody Nikkei saying that he would
love to see a kramnik in Carolina in a
future edition of this New York aqua
force italian-american Fabiano para Rana
also a really cool one for Americans to
watch absolutely you play chess here and
then you moved to Italy where he had a
lot more opportunity to play in close
tournaments and now he's also one of the
best players in the world top hands hole
five yes absolutely a great player in
fact and also thanks for the tweeter who
mentioned a tournament that Magnus
didn't win the Norway Masters Norway
Championships that the winner was Sergei
karyakin or Karjakin also very young
very very talented player originally
from the ukraine now representing Russia
look out for him so a lot of
extraordinarily youthful talented
players in this generation yeah that's
right and we want to thank you all for
your comments it's been great to hear
from everyone I mean the the comments on
on Twitter and also some of the
commentary to be getting via email
it's just it's great to know that people
appreciate this 20 min and I think we're
getting a lot of positive feedback yeah
and just address a subject that has
certainly gotten a zit our attention
here and a lot of the email and Twitter
is about it just a little reference we
have a high-speed DSL high speed cable
to for this weekend what we really
wanted to do to ensure that the show is
broadcast we brought in satellites so we
have a big bird in the sky we came
loaded to bear we wanted to make a great
show that you would all enjoy and
appreciate so just a shout out to our
entire technical team here they really
have done a magnificent job and I
especially enjoyed the intros and all of
those montage of footage Randy Randy put
together you know Rex exploiting his son
you know you gotta you gotta exploit
family and friends that's what life's
all about
but a shout out to them thank you and to
our audio people and everybody who made
it possible is oh wait and also Randy
who is the director of the spectrum
Studios on he made a guest appearance as
Jason you're gonna beat them up over
that thanks for the reminder
absolutely you were late for the
rehearsal that day that's in the second
act sacrament okay welcome back for that
one but we look like magnets actually
has me to move well Magnus has I'm gonna
be sick so do you think some he wishes
that he can play g5 and you know at
least threaten some kind of lover but
but uh
Magnus leeteuk that found earlier with
h4 so instead just g6 so we had these
last few moves I'm going back to just a
moment before the time control was
reached we saw this move rook a-1 a-2
just over protecting this c2 pond then
mysterious moved King a7 doesn't really
change the position King slid over to g1
king b6
King f1 g6 see how he done King G 1 and
we have an idea from an international
master Adam hunt
oh I think his sister Harriet hunt also
a very strong woman player from England
yeah British Women's Champion he said
what about the black walking around to
the Kings side to play g5 Wow
ok well thank you for that I believe you
have an idea right we were really we
were really desperate there for an idea
so the idea was suggested that to try to
a nerve white and to get him out of this
blockade is to make all of this King all
the trek all the way back to the Kings
side so that g6 g5 can be played well
one of the things that we were thinking
about earlier was wasn't there an
opportunity to play Knight takes before
so while black may go on this treasure
hunt of trying to get his king over here
at some moment there might be the move
Knight takes before that we had seen
earlier to try to stop that but thank
you very much Adam because really I was
coming up completely empty with this
situation and at least it's an idea
maybe it's a good one Maurice can you
chime in yes I was equally desperate and
came up with the same idea so I decided
to check it with the engine to see what
it thought about it because what are you
supposed to do in this position
unfortunately it ended up slapping me in
the face with a maneuver King to b7
blade Knight f2 so I said ok what are
you doing King c8 let's see what happens
and suddenly play Knight II D 3 and the
rook on D 2 is suddenly trapped and the
threat of king e1 is about to appear on
the board so black has to be extremely
careful for these kind of tricks in the
position so not so easy full of own to
prove himself in this position it just
looks like every idea he looks at is
coming up coming up nothing
and unfortunately for him he's still
looking at this problem of his polite on
a five why did he put it there grabbing
that pawn it hasn't moved since it took
that pawn frozen on a bad square and no
way to change the situation and I guess
if by the way someone said if pawns are
ponies what are Knights we know ponies
are like short they don't run that fast
Knights or horses the big there's they
run down the board and so that's my
analogy thoroughbreds even but not this
night on a five that night on a five is
stuck in mud and going nowhere fast
Jen yes Thank You Maurice why sometimes
like to call and called upon the
princesses because you all want to
become queens right so a pony is kind of
a corollary to that just in case the
pawn becomes a knight pounds can grow up
to be a knight I like that okay that
seems fair enough and again that that
was actually a nifty little maneuver
that Maurice just shared with us this
idea that in this position after the
move g6 we are seeing Magnus shuttling
as King back and forth between the G 1
and F 1 squares but that idea of Knight
F 2 with a sly plan of trapping the roof
well you got to be aware of that at
least and something I hadn't spotted
myself in the position so still
something to keep in mind for the bone
but in any case both players are absent
from the board at the moment I'm looking
at the webcam that's a bit of a surprise
oh yeah because we thought that they
would at this moment maybe be
considering the draw offer but it looks
like levana is going to continue to try
something here he has nothing to lose
for sure and by the way again Adam hunt
thank you very much I don't know if
Aronian has spotted your idea of moving
all the way to f6
but he just played the move King b7 so
it's on its way
yes so a lot of moves and a lot of
increments they're gonna be built up
well you know sometimes you just have to
exhaust every single possibility let's
anticipate for a moment that Magnus does
nothing he does nothing you played King
f1 instantly and we do get a situation
like this a consideration I'm not sure
it's a good Magnus Carlsen just playing
literally within 20 seconds to the board
bang right and you know black could
conceivably still go for that idea
another possible plan I'm not sure it's
a good one is to play like this to at
least get rid of this Knight on d3 and
maybe play for Knight to d4 so at the
moment I'm attacking the rook let's
imagine a trade for a moment a trade and
then trying to get the knight to d4 and
go after c2 this is a possibility I
think it's most likely going to end up
in a rook and pawn endgame that's going
to be even but okay just a try it's a
try that's right so predictions here on
how long this game is going to be you
know again considering the tournament
situation and what LaVon needs a draw or
a loss actually is the equivalent of the
same in terms of prize money playing all
out for the win not necessarily
recklessly I'm gonna give it another 15
minute 50 moves at least of maneuvering
that's right in 15 minutes and 15 moves
might actually not be that far away
because both players seem to be playing
pretty quickly at this point right and
do we have another move after let me
refresh the board and just give a look
at the clocks for a second and we do
have the move King c8
so Adam if there was a prize for best
suggestion you would have won it too bad
for you of honor being mentioned in a
show so much I think and we got reading
some nice comments about the show a
daniel wrench from chess comm says that
as a chess protest fan an American chess
player he wants to thank the Chess Club
mister Sinquefield and others for this
great event yeah absolutely
and yeah see you're getting lots of
Twitter's my goodness oh yeah yeah
people know this is their chance as
we're waiting for these two players to
grind out the egg and their chance to
get a little bit of air time and then
give her thoughts on what they thought
about this really historic event
absolutely we'll look back at this event
and say boy I was a part of that all
this fun and so again there's a planned
press conference did you mention oh yes
there's a press conference that will be
live streamed 45 minutes after the end
of this round that we're also gonna get
the winner which if somehow onion wins
and will be here for another couple
hours all right but Magnus Carlsen would
come down and talk to us for a bid and
then there will be a press conference 45
minutes later so a journalists or we've
got journalists all over the world here
we've got Grandmaster Ian Rogers and his
wife Cathy a photographer
we've got Julia Diane from the chest ROM
we've got damn Lucas from chess player
magazine we've got Mike Klein from chess
calm Janice Niecy and Sabrina
Siobhan UK and and Italy in Italy and
Dirk from Holland right Dirk young yes
that's right
I mean this is amazing and don't leave
yourself out you're the webmaster for
the USCS
there you go journalist here is out okay
get busy anything lady and we have a
hundred of course from Jess calm
strong my master he came and gave some
really insightful position
Terry in one of our shows and he's also
doing annotations and reports for
justice right and by the way he's taking
over some of the activities from our
dear friend Frederick Friedel who was
four decades in the face of chess bass
Alejandro moving into journalism which
is remarkable but okay oh yeah it's all
good it's all good
and we still have that and then later
after the press conference there'll be a
closing ceremony and where will that be
the closing ceremony and the trophy
ceremony are gonna be right during the
press conference so those of you in the
livestream can actually watch Magnus
Carlsen except the Sinquefield cup in
person and it looks like the jackets are
both on and I wonder if that means that
LaVon is cold or if that means that he's
ready to call it a day exactly and a
good time and a good fight with black
but not able to see any way to crack me
nor we do it well the guy who would give
things away and I remember it so well
from my struggles with Garry Kasparov
Garry Kasparov had this watch this
oversized watch that he would take off
at the start of the game he put it on an
over a score sheet he would write his
move put the watch on the score sheet
and whenever Garry put the watch back on
that was the indication that a it was
time for you to resign or be it was time
and he was willing to accept a draw that
when the watch came on it meant result
him I know Maurice you and I were there
at the deep-blue matches and it was
fascinating to watch that Garry
psychology that he used against
grandmasters had no effect against
nothing whatsoever for he's going off to
you to share those fond memories indeed
yes it was incredible how much the clock
watch was on in that competition you
know Gary always wears his emotions on
his sleeve and then what it's what made
us so intrigued why
touching him or at least one of the
things that made us intrigued watching
him there was also the jacket
yes which he very rarely had to take off
usually when Gary took off his jacket it
didn't mean it was time to go to work it
meant oh my goodness there's trouble on
the board we kept the jacket on it meant
you're not worrying me at all my watch
is off for now and when I know when it
comes back on exactly the scenarios you
said yes but when Gary took the jacket
off and Men whoa I lost control of the
position and now I've got to work and I
might even lose the game and he would
put tremendous energy in in that moment
when the jacket came back on it man I've
resolved all difficulties and either
it's going to be a draw or sorry you
completely screwed up in the time
pressure and now it's time for me to put
my watch on and slam dunk everything so
that body language is critical we know
it's part of chess you try to hide it as
much as possible here you see these two
cool customers giving away nothing
physically well clearly you see Magnus
very calm very relaxed Livan on the
other side working extremely hard trying
to prove something here in this position
so they still with the facial twitches
you don't see any of that as you see in
the Nakamura game but you know LaVon
wants to win and I would like to posit a
small strategy a possibility for LaVon
and that is since losing it really
doesn't matter for to him okay you could
lose the game and maybe some braiding
points but it's no difference in the
standings maybe as far as he's concerned
he'll try to get Magnus to overreach at
one point maybe he himself could go into
time trouble now that's a bit of a risky
strategy trying to go into time pressure
against the best player in the world and
you might lose in a silly way but it
might be the chance to get Magnus to try
to play for a winner we just saw Magnus
play that move Knight to f2 that the
computer has suggested trying to trap
this rook in and Magnus decide hey
here's a chance maybe I don't just sit
back maybe I get his rook
of course the Von's dropped the rook
back saw the
idea but he's trying to bait Magnus
maybe come on do something do you really
just want to draw to win try something
let's see what happens I don't think
it's gonna work but he's pulling out all
stops to see if he can maybe get the
game sharp and when get at least getting
a fight and have a chance at getting
into a playoff for the Sinquefield Cup
back to you Jaden yes okay so the move
Knight d3f to setting up that very sly
night II won d3 idea to ensnare the rook
with King e1 LaVon dropped back with his
rook with rook D to d8 and Magnus did
Magnus right yeah I think Magnus has
responded don't quite have the move yet
but I'm just thinking that Magnus is
going to reset his fortress and now say
hey look the rook is gone so what
happened Maurice further thoughts yes
big news the computers are now saying
white is the one who's better in this
position that the game has changed and
white is the one with a slight edge even
though he remains down upon now that the
black rook has left the position is now
back home on d8 that white has a chance
a plus 0.2 for edge despite being
material down and it the computer now
Houdini saying to bring the King to the
center and let's give a random move for
black and it doesn't have any really
good idea so black and move like king
here it sees a maneuver that's possible
Knight h3 going into g5 as being
possible but first maybe playing King d2
shoring up this side of the board and
slowly Black has really no plans to play
for so why can't white start doing
something so liking White's position is
not giving any clear direction however
as to how why it will improve the game
but it thinks wife's difficulties are
completely over in fact whites the one
with a slight edge so maybe just maybe
Carlsen might be thinking
I can win this game I know how will he
come out of the fortress and go for it
to decisively win and give Aronian a
chance or will he stay back
that's the big question of the hour as
we go into the waning moments of the
last round of the Sinquefield Cup Jenna
yes Wow boy and his posture sure has
changed well ok looking away looking
back at the board that would certainly
be a statement
well it's drama-filled all the way to
the very end and Magnus has been quoted
by Maurice earlier in our shows as
saying you there's no excuse for not
playing out the position at all and he
just feels that professional players
simply should not offer a draw
regardless of the position unless it's
as clear that the spectators as possibly
can be one of the things that Maurice
has you were talking I was trying to
wait I love this rook on d2 don't get me
wrong but on the other hand it was
trapped now with the move King b7 and
you mentioned that the computer is all
happy about Keaney - well here's a
thought after say King b6 and you did
mention this move King D - maybe shoring
up the Queen side well now in this
particular moment there is an idea for
black LaVon kept could play rook d8 a8
protecting the pawn on a6 hoping hoping
I'm not saying it's going to happen but
hoping that he could drop his Knight at
long last back to b7 playing the move a
6 a 5 and trying to say hey at last I am
a solid pawn up your other idea of
bringing the Knight to g5 however is
very disconcerting
after King b7 let's say Knight jumps to
h3 King b6 trying to set up for rook a8
well after the move Knight g5 you're
never going to get the chance to play
rook a8 because this pawn on e6 is
hanging and I don't
think black wants to offer that pawn as
bait
so still well well well within the
parameters of a draw I believe I think
that it's very likely this game will be
yes and Magnus Carlsen did point out and
tweet about the World Cup but he thought
the pressure was more in the organizers
to make it clear that you can't accept a
quick draw rather than the players so he
was making a comment about around in
which the drawers were rather quickly
right and the semi-finals you saw some
of that yes we blame them because
they're just trying to increase their
chances of winning the title right and
the candidates and they playing
exhausting a really stressful chess with
you know the match hangs finally on the
balance of each and every moves rather
it should be the organizer who should
disallow that because otherwise it's the
players who care more about being
ambassadors for the game are actually
being punished right you know which is
the point
not exactly the incentive structure you
want right something what's wrong with
that picture
going back to Murray score further
insight Maurice help us out in DD eyes
this idea for Aronian is really
intriguing you know how it is when you
desperately need a draw to win a
tournament we've all been there a draw
is enough you get first place
money's in your pocket so what do you
want to do sit there for hours and hours
and hours and be tortured by your
opponent or find a clear line something
forcing something direct that gives you
that draw or at least the chance to win
if Magnus is sitting there thinking
about this I want the draw LaVon knows
that so instead of playing a position
where he really has no chance to win
he's thinking why force anything let's
just keep moving pieces now it's not
great for us to fans because he's
shuffling back and forth but in his mind
he's he knows his opponent wants it how
can I make it happen I don't want to sit
here for 50 moves the reality is LaVon
could actually play another 50 moves
quite easily I mean wouldn't be hard to
do shuffle the rope back don't just
don't
he moves you notice how he's looking at
the scoresheet is in his head thinking I
don't want to repeat the position to
make these a guy claim a three-fold
repetition so let me just be clear on
that
but if I just sit here and do nothing
for a long time will he gets frustrated
when he realizes I'm willing to sit for
the next few hours and play now the fans
might be leaving by then but this guy is
after seventy thousand dollars first
place in an illustrious tournament and
now we see key key to having been played
by Magnus will Magnus come out of that
she'll The Tortoise put his head out to
say alright enough already
I want the draw it's too much to just be
sitting here so interesting strategy by
Levon he's an experienced veteran he's
going to test Magnus all the way down to
the end because really he's got
absolutely nothing to lose and it's
Magnus with absolutely everything to
lose in this situation so we'll see what
happens in the next dude maybe two hours
or so why not keep it going I mean and I
think I discovered a more prosaic reason
for putting the jackets back on many of
the fans have left to go to Lester's for
a beer to watch the end of this no it's
a little yeah temperature drop down
because every but really they're like
fur but of course the the ones who
remain there everywhere because they all
want to get an autograph or a photo with
Magnus they're hoping and Aronian of
course he's got a ton of fans himself
but I know that players are just bobbing
these players for autographs I mean
Hikaru came on the show earlier and just
said that he's never seen anything like
it that people are cheering for him as
he walks by he feels like an absolute
sports star here and he is he was on the
field at the Cardinals game and the Rams
game absolutely and we got another move
from looks like a Levon has just played
a move I'm thinking it's King be sick
yeah that looks like it looks like might
have been king b6 already tell from that
web cam
but let's put it on the board for so we
can see oops that's the wrong board
wrong window I mean so in case of king
b6 the idea that we were trying to
nurture was rook a8 and might be seven
but of course it is white to play I
think I can set up a checkmate if you
like Jen what's the a king B to move by
Magnus a rook eight eight move a knight
d1 or I'm not I'm getting it I'm getting
the wrong tempos I said I'm sorry
I see seven no I was trying to play
Knight c4 check and rook a so it could
play okay something right then you will
get your tech name well no the checkmate
I had a little bit more frustration oh
yeah you wanted King yes well this is a
bit of a self-made rook a 893 ninety
seven Knights e4 check oops that was the
checkmate variation I had in mind of
course it's not going to happen that I
just like when I see checkmate
variations I do like to share them like
this yeah it doesn't doesn't even seem
possible
exactly so we he did at LaVon pardon me
he did play King b6 and here's another
variation I don't think that this is
actually a very good one in this
particular case I don't think ninety one
is a very good move in this case because
there is this funny Knight check now
where do you go if your King doesn't
protect the knight doesn't say stay
safely waking up to you were to snag
that pawn on b3 or C - I see - right
then you just have to worry about just
impossible in between those grabbing a
pawn of our own
so king b6 king e to king here so 91
doesn't work I think our main move had
been king e - let's just follow this
line of thought for a moment
locate the only idea we've been able to
come up with so that we could release
our night we were looking at a line
light night h3 night back at long last
black is ready to utilize his extra pawn
with the move a six a five that white is
just in time with this extremely
annoying move Knight h5 the knight h3 to
g5 right we want to be able to play 94
and a five in this position and then
everything would be lovely but well
maybe maybe there's still the still
juice here in night b7 to d8 at least at
the moment black is holding on to
everything
and I wonder if the where the knight can
maneuver to next well this night could
possibly go here but at least finally
we're finding some breakthrough ideas or
at least ideas that keep the winning
chances for law lavona alive and maybe
this game is about to flare up again
Maurice do you agree with me that we're
seeing opportunities for LaVon that he
didn't have say ten moves ago no I don't
think so yes I think that he really
doesn't have opportunities but he has
the whisper of opportunities I think
what he's doing is he's saying to Magnus
maybe I'll do something maybe the idea
you just said is possible
clearly Magnus is fine and should be
fine for a long time but LaVon is saying
I'm going to keep trying and I want you
to think about what may happen the in
lavon's case any suggestion of
idea like you said with rookie aid and
maybe being able to drop his Knight back
and play a five any suggestion of
consolidation is a problem for Magnus
because he's busy thinking I don't have
to do anything I can just shuffle back
and forth and then suddenly he sees well
maybe there's an idea on the other side
of the board if he has to look at all of
lavon's ideas it becomes harder for the
defender i we know that the defense is
usually harder than the attack because
the defender has to calculate everything
all lines while they attack it just has
to find the one line that works so
Carlsen will have to keep being
confident in this situation don't really
do anything keep his position solved and
he should be okay it doesn't seem as if
LaVon has much Livan on the other hand
should just keep doing small things
trying to improve his position and see
what happens see if he can get crossing
to come out of his shell but again
carson looks like he's either in his
living room or laying back on a chair on
the beach i mean he doesn't look at all
concerned about what's going to happen
so maybe five years ago ten years ago
when he was a little kid but now that
he's a veteran of the circuit you're not
going to cause these psychological ploys
to work on him i don't think in this
kind of position Jenni yes and now we
have our final time control so twelve
minutes for Carlson and nine minutes for
neon so a lot different from earlier in
the game when Carlson was way below on
time he was actually using his increment
for the last few moves of the time
control what do you mean by the third
time control Jen
I meant laughs okay final time the final
time control okay so how it works is the
players got a 30 minute bonus after
moved 40 and what you're saying is
there's no more bonus time and they're
only going to have to they're gonna have
to rely upon the 30 seconds that they
receive to be so hard in the second
position okay but if it flares up yeah
that's something that we definitely
should be paying attention to and as we
know I mean we're sitting here in our
broadcast studio and
joining the action having a lot of fun
commenting on the players games
we're not that stressed but these guys
might be getting fatigued and that was
where a lot of their interviews they
spoke about their stamina and the need
and it looks and looks like there might
have been a verbal offer of a draw in
this position and Magnus not twirling
upon twirling his pawn and to be clear
who offered the draw
Livan offered a draw and Magnus is
thinking about Berlin Magnus thinking
not now that he's got the offer of a
draw you thinking wait is that good
Wow I better check and make sure that
everything is good here most people in
this situation was seventy thousand
dollars let's say thank you very much
and have a nice day he was under
pressure for a long time would be like
okay bang one minute but instead
thanking me over and this is actually
kind of cool I think all the kids out
there watching this take a cue from
Magnus and somebody offers you a drawl
never say yes right away is
consideration what's going on never say
yes right away unless you're about the
flag or something because you know that
draw offer does not expire until you've
made your move right and I seen people
do it make it make a blunder offer a
draw on their opponents so excited
because I thought their position was bad
that I guess well in this case I mean
Magnus thinking about it but looking at
the tournament standings I mean I must
say and the position well I would I
would say thank you and great tournament
Levon and thank you for the draw offer
but Magnus true to himself he said that
professional should play till the very
end maybe thinking about doing just that
and defying what mere mortals do Maurice
psychology awesome I mean fantastic
psychology because these guys are gonna
play so off and course down the road the
pressure on Levon and saying you know
you might offer me a draw in a situation
like this but I am going to fight to the
very end Maurice what are your thoughts
I think it's bogus I think he's sitting
there thinking Yama 70 G's got it there
is no way I could imagine him making
another move that would be incredible if
he actually played another move on this
board I think now you see for the first
time a bit more agitated his body has
his body language has shifted
dramatically maybe like five or six
times in the last two minutes sitting
there thinking about his position he is
still okay and maybe he can make a
couple of moves and then later offer
Levana draw but maybe LaVon will put the
shoe back up on the other foot and say
uh-uh
you try to embarrass me I'm gonna have
to do the same to you
so you see here how he's shifting
constantly he's got to be a little bit
nervous as clock is ticking down it's
time as far as he's concerned she's been
donated gifted the draw certainly you
would think he would take it but he's
adding drama to a situation that it
seems you would have expected at all
fascinating to see if he makes a move
with the fact that his 70,000 has
literally been handed to him it's more
than just and he has been incredible the
draw offer decided to continue with 70
grand in his pocket he could win or
there's nothing beneficial to him to
making another move absolutely nothing
and he has actually decided to continue
playing and a lot of other results to
enter this is simply incredible that
he's done this very impressive from the
young phenom a real statement about his
fortitude and determination and
willingness to fight I love it
absolutely incredible decision by Magnus
I hope lots of young students all over
the world are watching this and taking a
cue from this guy I mean he's been
extremely successful so it's not about
the money here right he's got a lot more
money on the line against Anand and I
think that might be in the back of his
head Anand we're gonna have really long
games you might offer me in a draw in a
situation where it seems like I'm gonna
jump at it I'm just gonna keep playing
well and again I think it goes to his
professionalism and I mean he's true to
his word Magnus has been a very
forthright very honest clear principal
player he says hey listen there's simply
no excuse
for not playing to a finish and he's
showing it now here he's been gifted
first prize he says no that's not what
I'm about what I'm about is showing you
no high drama in chess and maybe I don't
think he's thinking so much of the
rating points maybe he is or maybe he's
just simply trying to say a statement to
his nearest and closest rival just
because you want to draw and want to
give me the tournament it doesn't mean
that I want the draw and maybe you know
he's thinking down the road or like I
say it's just about who he is as a
player and as a person he wants to show
what fighting chess is really about and
I actually think it's really I really
think it's a very shrewd psychological
decision tonight I mean the message of
the sense to his rivals it just people
already you know people used to say that
when they played Kasparov it was so
intimidating and they would also often
play underneath their normal level
though their level because he just like
had such a energy and also he's the
number one player in the world now you
have not only the fact that Magnus is
the number one player in the world but
you also have this aura where you know
you might never be able to offer haha
right I like that I think it's